buenos días keiko fujimori junto a su
comando de campaña presentado vídeos y
fotos y esto es para según dijo ahí a
como una prueba de lo que llamó
irregularidades la estrategia legal de
sus asesores es llevar este material al
jurado nacional de elecciones para con
esto intentar frenar el avance pedro
castillo en realidad el organismo
electoral va a tomar una decisión pero
las cosas no están definidas el terreno
es parejo faltan contabilizar los votos
que vienen del extranjero así como de
las zonas rurales y la presidencia del
perú puede ser para cualquiera de los
dos candidatos precisamente le quería
preguntar por eso aún faltan los votos
del extranjero y fujimori espera que
esos votos le favorezcan que dice
castillo en medio de las llamadas
vigilias ciudadanas de sus partidarios
el izquierdista pedro castillo dice que
va a respetar los resultados pero él no
cree en la total normalidad del conteo
de votos por eso le exige a la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales que
cuide tanto el procesamiento del conteo
de los votos antes de que estos sean
publicados el llamado a sus
simpatizantes a estar alerta y éstos le
obedecen llegas en vigilias alrededor de
la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales con cánticos tambores y
arengas hacen una presión mediática y
han acordonado del área la policía
desplegado
una fuerte dotación de efectivos para
darle seguridad al organismo electoral y
evitar que se produzcan desmanes